[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 105,
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi, Melanie?
How are you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good.
How was Thanksgiving for you?
MARK MANDEL: Thanksgiving
was good, just hung out
with some friends.
How about yourself?
MELANIE WARRICK:
Same-- it was really
nice to have some time with
friends and family and food.
MARK MANDEL: Food--
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's my favorite part
about the holiday.
MARK MANDEL: --a lot of food.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's true.
Awesome.
So this week, we
have Myles Borins
joining us, a fellow
developer advocate,
but active participant
in the Node.js community.
We're going to have
a good chat with him.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That will be fun.
And that is still going
to be with Francesc.
Because Francesc did all these
great interviews before he
left several weeks back.
Mark and Francesc and Myles will
have a good chat about Node.js.
And also-- to note that
Google is a Platinum
sponsor of the Node Foundation.
MARK MANDEL: Yup, yup.
So we're going to talk about
that involvement as well.
And then, after
that, we're going
to have an
interesting discussion
around blameless
postmortems-- but how
to do public blameless
postmortems, ones that you
share with the outside world.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's not
always an easy thing to do.
But constructive criticism
is crucial to improve things.
OK, but before we
get into all of that,
let's talk about the
cool things of the week.
So to get us started, one of
the things that I definitely
think is very cool
is that Google
has cut the prices on GPUs and
specifically the Nvidia Tesla
GPUs, which are attached to our
on-demand Google Compute Engine
virtual machines.
And basically, it's
been cut by about 36%.
MARK MANDEL: That's
pretty awesome.
And as well as that, if you're
doing a batch job processing
with GPUs, they've
also lowered the price
of preemptible local
SSDs by almost 40%,
compared to
on-demand local SSDs.
Basically, things are cheaper.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Cheaper is good.
MARK MANDEL: Cheaper is good.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And GPUs, they're
popular, especially when you
get into machine learning,
especially when you
get into deep learning.
So having machines that you
can use that are cheaper
are very helpful.
MARK MANDEL: That is good.
So speaking of doing machine
learning and big compute jobs
and batch processing
and all that stuff,
we're now offering the
Skylake CPUs in extra regions
that we weren't doing before.
So now we have them available
in South Carolina, Mumbai,
and Singapore, joining Iowa,
Oregon, Belgium, and Taiwan,
bringing the total
number of GCP regions
with Skylake to seven, globally.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Seven is a good number.
MARK MANDEL: Seven
is a good number.
And just for fun, we're
also lowering the price.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's even better.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so lowering
the cost of Skylake VMs
by 6% to 10%, depending
on your configuration.
MELANIE WARRICK: It seems
to be a theme, frankly,
with the way this
last week has been.
Everything's getting
cut in price.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's online sales time.
It's after Thanksgiving,
in the US at least.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So it seems
like a common trend.
MELANIE WARRICK: Last
thing we want to mention
is, Martin Gorner, who's also a
developer advocate on our team,
was speaking earlier
this month at Devoxx.
And he extended his
series he's been
doing around how to do
TensorFlow without a PhD
or, I think, deep
learning without a PhD.
And in this series, he's
added on to information
around deep learning and modern
convolutional neural nets.
As well as, he's talking
about RNN architectures
and deep reinforcement learning.
So those videos-- we
have the links to them.
And we're going to be
putting them up on our blog.
MARK MANDEL: Super
great resources
to learn about all this stuff.
It's good.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's very helpful
to let people know that you
don't have to necessarily dive
deep and spend many years
understanding before you
can experiment with this.
All right, let's go ahead
and dive into the interview.
So next up, the interview with
Myles and Mark and Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very happy today
to welcome a new member of our
team-- actually, not that new.
MYLES BORINS: Not that new.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He's
been here for a while--
Myles Borins.
How are you doing, Myles?
MYLES BORINS: I am doing
great and feeling really new.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's good.
MARK MANDEL: He's still got
that new DA smell though.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, not
looking that new anymore
though.
MYLES BORINS: Good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Anyway, we have Myles.
And he's going to be joining
us to talk about Node.
And we're going to be talking
about Node and the governance
and how it works and all
the open source organization
and all of that stuff.
But before we start
with all of that,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself.
What do you do at Google?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, so as was
mentioned, my name is Myles.
My other name is Borins.
Together, it's Myles Borins.
And I'm a developer advocate
on Google Cloud Platform.
I focus primarily on Node.js.
But I also dabble in Compute and
Kubernetes and Cloud Functions
and pretty much
anywhere where you can
run Node or do Nodey things.
I'm on the Technical
Steering Committee
of Node.js Foundation,
where I was recently
elected the Technical
Steering Committee director.
So I also sit on the board of
directors of the Foundation.
I'm one of the primary
release managers running
most of our LTS programs.
So most of the version
4 and version 6 releases
and some of the version 8
releases are coming from me.
And lately, most of my work
has actually been around V8
and making sure that
the Node project can
have the most modern
versions of V8 as possible.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So actually, why don't we
start with some history.
Most people probably
know what Node is.
But maybe, some people don't.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit about the language,
where it came from.
What's that background like?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, totally.
I'll give a super abridged
version of the keynote
that I gave at Node Interactive
recently, Google was there.
We had about five different
talks and three keynotes.
And one of mine was one
of the closing keynotes.
And I called it Node wave 6.
And it was just about
how there has been
many different ways of Node.
Node was originally created
in 2009 by Ryan Dahl
and presented a JSComp VU.
That would be what we
would consider wave 1.
And Ryan was the BDFL, which is
short for Benevolent Dictator
for Life, of the project
or about, like, I think,
two or three years.
And then the project
was taken over
by Isaac Schluter,
who ran the project
for a similar amount of time.
And then T.J. Fontaine--
not T.J. Holowaychuk--
T.J. Fontaine took over for
what I would dub Node wave 3.
The project was forked
in 2015 into iOjs,
which was Node wave 4.
And it was put into a foundation
later that year, which was,
theoretically, Node wave 5.
And that was the
release of Node.js 4.0.
Since then, Node has
been in a foundation
for the last two years.
We're up to Node.js 8 right now.
Node.js 9 is coming out
at the end of this month.
And yeah, we've been
doing a lot of discussion
about Node wave 6,
because we're starting
to feel a little bit
of the growth pain now
and trying to re-imagine
some of our governance
and technical direction, to
allow us to continue to scale.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I
think it's pretty cool
that you were
mentioning at least
two different organizations.
You mentioned the Technical
Steering Committee.
And you also mentioned
the Foundation.
What are those?
Let's start with the
Foundation, for instance.
What is the Node Foundation?
MYLES BORINS: Yes, so
the Node.js Foundation
is a nonprofit.
I believe it's a 501(c)(3)?
That's the thing
that non-profits are?
MARK MANDEL: Sounds about right.
MYLES BORINS: Maybe I got
one of those digits wrong.
But the Foundation has a number
of different member-partners.
And each of the
member-partners donate money,
based on their membership level.
There's silver,
gold, and platinum.
Google recently came in
as a platinum sponsor.
And that actually brought one
of our colleagues, Sarah Novotny
to the board of directors,
which is really exciting.
The board of directors is
made up of representations.
One person for each
member from the platinum
level of sponsorship and
then a certain number
of members from both
gold and silver,
depending on how
many sponsors there
are in each of those levels.
The board of directors
right now is--
I want to say--
11 people.
And those 11 individuals
are essentially
responsible for the fiduciary
duty of the foundation.
So The Foundation
has all this money.
What do we use the money for?
How does it get handled?
The Foundation itself owns
the codebase of Node.js
and has lawyers on hand.
So like, if someone
decides to sue us
because they think that
we're causing problems
with licenses and stuff, the
Foundation would protect us.
That actually is
one thing that's
really great about foundations
in general for open source
software, is it protects
all of the maintainers
and contributors.
So if you're a contributor
and you contributed
code that, maybe, somehow down
the line, had some GPL in it
and you didn't
know, the Foundation
would be there to
support and help you.
The Technical Steering Committee
and the board of directors
kind of report to each other.
Although, like in a
classic org structure,
you would maybe see the
board of directors as higher
than the TSC.
I, as the TSC director, am kind
of the emissary between both
of those organizations.
One of the interesting things
about our technical governance
though is that the
board of directors
has no technical oversight
over the project,
nor does the Foundation.
The project's
technical governance
is completely overseen by the
Technical Steering Committee
and the volunteers on it.
So the board can't
show up and be
like, hey, we want you to bake
GRPC into the binaries of Node.
That wouldn't fly.
But members of the Google team
who are represented on the TSC
have been working really hard
to get HTTP2 natively supported,
not behind a flag,
in Node 8, which
will allow us to have
non-binary versions of GRPC.
So you can have influence
and corporations
can drive influence,
but not through money.
It's through participation,
action, and engagement.
MARK MANDEL: So what
exactly does the TSC do?
MYLES BORINS: So that's a
little bit of a loaded question,
because we're in the
process of figuring out
what the TSC should do.
What the TSC has
historically done has been--
responsible for the overall
technical governance
and direction of the project.
So this has to do with
high-level initiatives
and high-level vision.
So we've been doing,
since April, for example,
plans for having more
modern versions of V8
in the 8.x LTS release.
And that's involved ongoing
work from various TSC members.
At the moment, whenever
there is certain levels
of technical disagreements,
those get floated to the TSC
to either have the
Technical Steering
Committee itself reach consensus
over or vote, if necessary.
I think one thing
that's worth mentioning
is the technical
project of Node itself
is governed in a model
called "consensus seeking."
So essentially, any
person on the planet
can send a pole request to Node.
And if a committer
has signed off on it
and it has been there for more
than 48 hours without anyone
rejecting it, we consider
that seeking consensus.
And it can just land on Master.
We have a number of
processes in place,
from testing to CI
to smoke testing
to the waterfall of
our release process,
that offer many different lines
of where we can catch things
if they end up
being problematic,
if they land to quickly.
But generally, we've been
trying to empower our committers
as much as possible.
And we try to, as
much as possible,
not have things go to a vote
and, even further, not go
to the Technical
Steering Committee.
So we had a Technical Steering
Committee meeting this morning,
for example.
And we spent the first
1/3 of it talking
about the new version of
V8 that recently turned off
escape analysis,
because of a bug, which
makes async/await slower.
And so we had to do some
planning about how are we
were going to handle that.
The other 1/3 of it
was spent talking
about our build infrastructure
and ways in which
we can improve and make our
CI and build infrastructure
more reliable.
And then 1/3 of it
was spent talking
about a document
we're drafting right
now on higher-level expectations
for leaders in the project.
And so, all those
things are things
that are under the purview
of the TSC currently.
Although, I'd really like
to see us move the TSC
towards more forward-facing
proactive initiatives--
finding things that
need to be done,
creating initiatives around
it, finding champions
and stakeholders to lead
those initiatives, rather
than the day-to-day
handling of code conflict,
and finding more ways to empower
our collaborators to handle
that.
One of the challenges
that we have right
now is that, as far as career
growth in the project goes,
you become a collaborator.
And then your next
thing you can do
is be on the steering committee.
And not everyone really
cares about governance stuff.
I almost consider it similar
to, like, a management
track and individual contributor
track in a corporation.
And so, right now,
what we're trying to do
is figure out, what are
more individual contributor
tracks that we can be making
for our collaborators,
so they can have career
growth and project growth?
Have things that
they can report back
to their organizations about
things that they're doing
and why the money being
invested makes sense?
And actually, we've been
talking to Sarah Novotny
and taking some notes from how
the Kubernetes project does it.
And we may do some
iteration based on that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you mentioned something
that sounded almost
dangerous to me,
especially coming from
the Go community, which
is you mentioned
that, if someone sends
a change to the language and it
has not been rejected during 48
hours, and it passes
all tests and stuff,
then it just
basically gets merged.
MYLES BORINS: Mm-hm.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So can
I just go now and, like--
I don't know-- do
something crazy
and add-- like, I'm going to
add Go routines to Node.js.
Why not?
And I just send my change.
And if I send that on Friday,
maybe, luckily, Saturday
and Sunday, no one will
notice and we'll get merged?
MYLES BORINS: So three
different things there.
The first being,
there's actually
an extension to the rule for
weekends that make it 72 hours.
The second would be--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
OK, that's good.
MYLES BORINS: --is you would
actually need collaborators
to sign off on it.
So we trust our collaborators.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK.
MYLES BORINS: We
give commitbits.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MYLES BORINS: There's about
100 people with commitbits.
We trust those people to
make the right decision.
If they don't, then they
have to answer for it.
And the third is, like,
our waterfall release
process that we have offers,
as I said-- like, maybe it's
on Master.
But we can revert from
Master pretty quickly.
And the last bit is--
and this is kind of
counter-intuitive--
we don't actually control
the language at all in Node.
We embed V8, which is a
JavaScript virtual machine
from the Chrome browser.
V8 implements the
ECMA-262 specification
that's specified by TC-39, which
is the technical committee that
makes the JavaScript language.
So we're actually downstream
from the language itself.
So I know I'm being
pedantic, but I just
thought people may be
interested in this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, that's
an important difference.
MYLES BORINS: So for
example, in theory,
if you wanted to, you could
go and make C++ changes to V8
to change the way that
strings work to be not
to the specification.
But no one is going to
sign off on that landing.
And we have pretty strict
process around, like,
what can land on V8.
And generally, we
don't land anything
into the V8 tree that hasn't
been approved upstream.
MARK MANDEL: So you mentioned
this a couple of times.
But let's talk
about it directly.
You talked about how Google
is now a platinum sponsor.
Sarah Novotny is
now on the board--
MYLES BORINS: Mm-hm.
MARK MANDEL: --I think it was.
So what does that entail?
Like, what is
platinum sponsorship?
You talked a little
bit about it.
And what does it mean, now that
Google is part of this program?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, so
if you go to nodejs.org,
at the top of the page, there's
a link that says Foundation.
And if you click
on Board there, you
can see a little bit more
information about the board
and who's on there.
We can notice that I actually
need to send a pole request,
because Sarah Novotny's
name is not on there yet.
And I'll do that
after this call.
But the board of
directors, as far as
how the Foundation is
concerned and what we get,
we've given a certain amount
of money to the Foundation
at a platform level
of sponsorship.
That gives us a seat at
the board of directors.
And having a seat at the board
of directors allows us to have,
to a certain extent, a say in
how that money is being used
and how the project
is being supported
and how higher-level
initiatives are being done.
So the majority of the things
that the board focuses on
tend to either be in a support
role to the core project
or in a marketing
role to Node itself.
So the Foundation's
responsible for throwing
Node Interactive, which was
the big conference that we
were at last year.
And the money that's
in the Foundation
floats the conference
being able to happen,
until it gets back the
money from ticket sales.
The money in the Foundation
also pays for the salaries
of our executive team.
So we have an
executive director.
We have an education
community manager.
We have a number of different
marketing individuals
that we have on contract from
the Linux Foundation, which
is worth mentioning.
The Node Foundation
is actually, like,
a child project of
the Linux Foundation.
I'm definitely not
using the correct terms.
But the Linux
Foundation has a process
of spinning up foundations under
the Linux Foundation, which
is how the Node
Foundation was formed.
There is marketing
subcommittees and there's
interest groups
that get spun up,
depending on different
things that need to be done
and different projects
that are going on.
But at the highest
level, the board
is handling mostly
fiduciary duties.
One of the great things
that they signed off on,
for example, two years ago,
was creating a travel fund
for collaborators who are
not with member companies
to be able to attend our events
and collaborator summits.
So I think, up until
this point, we've
probably spent almost $50,000
over the last two years
flying out and supporting
various collaborators
from the project attending
our events and collaborators
summits.
And actually, any
collaborator or even member--
it's not always clear.
But we try to let people know.
Anyone who's a member of the
Foundation, which costs $50,
is eligible to apply
for a travel stipend.
Generally, these all have to
be approved by the Technical
Steering Committee.
And they're not going to
approve individuals who
are not actively participating.
But if you're even just mildly
participating in the project
and you pay $50 or if you even
just get committed and get
on a working group, you get
that membership for free,
you can get free trips
around the world,
on the Foundation's dime, to
go and collaborate with people.
And this is a really great
service that we offer.
We have students.
And we have education faculty.
We have people working for small
companies, people who normally
wouldn't necessarily get
these opportunities be
able to come out and still be
a large part of the project.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And you mentioned that Sarah
Novotny has joined you.
Many people probably
know her from her work.
She's down in Kubernetes.
You mentioned, she's brought
some of her experience
about managing open-source
projects from Kubernetes
over to the Nerd Foundation.
Are there any
particular lessons or--
MYLES BORINS: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --or interesting
stories out of that?
MYLES BORINS: So it's
actually like a fun
kind of "dragon eating its
own tail" kind of thing.
When the Kubernetes Foundation
was starting to put together
their governance model
was right around the time
that I joined Google.
And they were really
interested in how
Node had done things
and things that we
thought worked and things
that we thought didn't work.
And I ended up having
a call with them.
I was one of many people
that they ended up
interviewing in the process of
coming up with their governance
model.
And then, now that they've
solidified their governance
model and are moving
forward with it,
we then went back
and interviewed
them to find out, like,
hey, what did you do?
And one of the
biggest differences
that they have
which, as Googlers,
you're going to recognize
some of these patterns,
they don't actually have
the idea of a committer.
They have reviewers.
They have acceptors.
They have owners.
And they have maintainers.
The maintainers,
there's only a handful.
And those are the
only ones who actually
have ownership over the repo.
But they actually
have a Commit QBot.
And so reviewers can
go and review any code.
They can plus 1
and minus 1 things.
But if an accepter
accepts something,
they can totally accept
it even if a reviewer
has minused 1 something.
An owner has veto
rights over all of that.
I also could be totally
not doing justice
to how that actually works.
This is what I've learned
in the last five days.
But from that, what
we're trying to look
at in Node is, what kind of
level-ups for our committers
could we offer?
And ones that we're
thinking about, for example,
would be, like, security.
A lot of people want to get
more involved in the security
work for the project.
So we're looking--
and this is something
we would talk to the
Foundation about.
We would go and talk to
the board of directors
and say, hey, can we find money
to create a security training
and onboarding for committers?
And then, when we create
that program, which will then
probably also have to go
to legal for due diligence,
we would be able to take
committers who are interested
and put them through this
onboarding, which would then
have them trained for
being involved in handling
embargoed security information.
And we're looking at changing
our embargo policy right now,
so that we can
bring in more people
to review stuff and have a
much smaller team of people who
are actually handling security
vulnerabilities as they come
in.
We're talking about spinning
up a mentorship program where,
again, if you go through a
certain training or a number
of different things, you
can get a mentorship bit,
in the same way that you
would get a commitbit.
And now, you can be responsible
for mentoring people
in the project.
So we're trying
to find a handful
of different
initiatives like this,
even potentially
explicitly dividing
the difference between
reviewers and landers
of code, which is kind
of straight-lifted
from the Kubernetes technical
governance structure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So all
of this sounds very good.
But now, I'm going
to ask a question
that you might not like.
But that's my job.
So why does Google
pay you to do this?
MYLES BORINS: Shh.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL:
Francesc, go to sleep.
Just Go to sleep.
MYLES BORINS: Well, first
of all, I'm no scrub.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: Ugh.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's a
reference to a inside joke.
MARK MANDEL: That's a
terrible inside joke.
We were referring
to the TSC as TLC.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that's a very bad joke.
Please continue.
MARK MANDEL: Also
showing our age.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Please continue.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes.
Yes, just creep along.
MYLES BORINS: So on top
of not being a scrub,
Google's investing a
lot of money in Node.
And this includes better
support on App Engine.
We have quite a number
of full-time [INAUDIBLE]
who are working on node-related
projects, such a Stackdriver
or Cloud Functions.
Node being successful,
Node working,
and Node being
stable and reliable
is part of a major story
for us selling our products
and services that we're
building on top of Node
and building for use of Node.
I don't have all of the numbers.
And I don't want to say
something that's wrong.
So I'm going to hand-wave
it a little bit.
But I do know that I've seen
numbers that show [INAUDIBLE]
on, like, App Engine Flex, Node
is one of the most-often spun
up platforms.
On GitHub, JavaScript is
the number one language.
Guess what number 10 is?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pascal.
MYLES BORINS: Type Script.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I actually thought
you were going to say Go.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I was like, that's--
blah.
MYLES BORINS: No, I think Go
is, like, three or something.
And it's growing real fast.
No, but it's
sandwiching the top 10.
And even just a language
that compiles to JavaScript
is one of the fastest-growing
platforms that's out there.
I think that there
is a certain form
of empathy in the code itself.
And some of the
new patterns that
are coming out in the
language, such as async/await,
are making it even more
approachable for developers.
And it's just really
amazing how quickly
you can get up and get running
and get prototypes going.
And yeah, maybe it will never
outperform, like, really,
really, really,
well-written Go routines.
But I think, for
a lot of people,
especially when you can scale
horizontally, it's good enough.
And they care more
about developer velocity
than engineering purity.
And that's not to say that you
can't engineer really, really
cool stuff with Node too.
But just, more in the sense
that, for a lot of teams,
the velocity of
Node is a huge sell.
And Google has
recognized that and is
investing in the platform.
So having me, like,
right in there,
I see it as hedging the bet.
It's like, they need to
invest on Node being healthy
and Node being successful, or
all the other money is kind of
flushed down the toilet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a very good point.
MYLES BORINS: Do you
get to keep my job now?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We'll
talk about that later.
So you mentioned real quick
that one of the reasons
is we actually invest heavily
in Node, because we also use,
heavily, Node.
And we provide ways to use Node
on our Google Cloud platform.
Is there something that
you could share about,
what is the future?
Like, it's a typical
question that, normally,
you say, no, because we
don't share roadmaps.
But is there any roadmap
you'd like to share?
MYLES BORINS: Well,
one thing that's
coming pretty soon that's
exciting is web sockets.
For myself, the
first time I ever
used Node was actually building
an art installation, where
I wanted to use a website to
pick between different states.
And I tried a whole bunch of
different ways of doing it.
And I kept failing, both
gracefully and miserably.
And eventually, I came
across this tutorial
using Node in Socket I/O.
And I had a prototype up
and running in, like,
10 or 15 minutes.
And to me, that's
the magic of Node.
If you've just written a
little bit of website-y things,
you can actually
get something that
does what you need it to
do in a fairly short order.
Web sockets are a
really, really great tool
for quickly prototyping
distributed applications,
chat applications, games--
which I know Mark has a
lot of feelings about.
And so this isn't only for Node.
But I do think that the
eventual support of web
sockets on App Engine and
Google Cloud Platform,
as a whole, outside
of just Kubernetes,
is a huge win for the various
platforms that will get it.
MARK MANDEL: And what
stuff do you really like
about GCP and Node right now?
MYLES BORINS: So about
GCP and Node right now--
I'm a big fan of
cloud functions.
I think it's a really cool
way to slowly break away
complexity from applications.
One of the examples that I often
use is just, like, a mailer.
So if you're having
someone who signs up
for a website for an account
and then, when they sign up
for the account, you want
to send them a welcome email
or something like that,
these small little tasks
are easily broken out
into cloud functions,
things that don't need to
be extremely performant.
If they have a cold boot,
it's not the end of the world.
If they come 30 seconds
later, it's not a big deal.
You can, really quickly,
without a lot of oversight,
just break out all
this complexity
from larger-scale
applications and utilize it.
That's one place--
Kubernetes Node Docker-- that
stack, I'm so excited about.
You combine that with
multi-cloud and federating over
spaces.
And I think it's really--
oh!
Oh my god, I'm going to say it.
I think it's going to create
a digital transformation.
MARK MANDEL: Whoa.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Whoa.
MYLES BORINS: Sorry, sorry.
But genuinely, I'm really
excited about that technology
stack.
It's not without its warts.
But I think Google has
first-class support
for Kubernetes.
It's really easy to
get started with GKE.
And there isn't too
much of a ritual
that you need to do
to get a Node app up
and running in a cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about Node itself?
What are the things that are
coming up with Node that you
think are very exciting?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah,
well, just last night, I
was finishing up
our 8.7.0 release,
which is going to have a
newer version of V8 6.1 in it.
There's discussions that we're
going to try to get V8.6.2
into Node 8, which would
give us Import as a keyword,
which is dynamic import.
It's part of our
ES module support
that we're introducing into
Node, which is pretty exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well, we are
running out of time.
But we do like to
give our guests
the one shot to be able to say,
basically, whatever they want.
Is there anything
you want to plug?
Or anything we haven't managed
to mention in today's episode
that you want to make
sure our listeners hear?
MYLES BORINS: Yeah, so
cloud.google.com/node.js--
you can go there to just
learn about getting started
with Node on Cloud Platform.
I didn't really plug
Stackdriver too much.
There's some real
magic with Stackdriver
that you can do for, like,
live debugging of apps
that are in production.
You know, write an
app with console log,
Deploy it with
Stackdriver on GCP.
And your logs are just there
and you can just look at them.
And that's really cool.
If you're also looking at
getting started with Node,
nodeschool.io is a really
amazing place to go and look.
There's tons of
tutorials that you
can run on your terminal that
are really great at getting
people up and running.
And if you look it up,
there's a high probability
that you have a local
Node School chapter,
where you can show up and get
live mentoring to help you
through the problems.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Great,
well, Myles, thank
you so much for taking
the time with us today.
It was really great to hear all
about Node and its governance
and how Google Cloud has
been organized with it.
MYLES BORINS: No, thank you
for inviting me and giving me
some tender loving
care as you listen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: See ya.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Well, thanks, Myles, for that.
That was great.
It was good to get some overview
of the Node.js Foundation--
and appreciate the insights
that you were able to share.
I think it's time for
our question-of-the-week.
Ready?
I feel like we need
a drum roll for this.
[DRUM ROLL]
How would you do a public
blameless postmortem?
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So this is an interesting topic.
I am definitely
not going to claim
to be an absolute expert on it.
And I'm going to start
referring listeners
to some other articles.
But the whole idea
here being, we've
talked about doing blameless
postmortems on other episodes
about doing SRE stuff.
But there's a great article that
came out recently from our CRE
team, our Customer
Reliability Engineering team,
about how to do public ones.
So something goes down.
Something bad happens.
There's an outage.
How do you put out a
post-mortem, basically saying--
and why should you put
out a postmortem, saying,
this is what went wrong and
this is what we should do?
So I think there's a lot of
things we can talk about here.
I think the short version--
and you should definitely read
the article, it's really great--
is like, why should you do this?
And I think the idea here is
also about customer trust.
So what would you actually
put in a postmortem?
So something like,
why did it happen?
So what went wrong?
Could it have been worse?
And also, how can you make sure
that it didn't happen again?
So as a customer, you can
read this and be like, oh, I
see something went wrong.
We're all human.
These things happen.
But I can see that
you've put things
in place now the will ensure
that this thing won't happen
again.
That aids trust.
That transparency aids trust.
And I think that's
good for everyone.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's important to be
able to focus on how to improve
and how to make things better.
It's also important
to think about what
you don't want to say.
And to drive that
trust, you definitely
don't want to say the names
of the humans involved.
You don't want to say the
names of the internal systems.
You want to avoid
customer-specific information.
So focus on what went wrong
and talk about it from a
"how can we make this better?"
Avoid the blame game.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
And definitely be aware
of your audience as well
and how much information is the
right amount of information.
And I think there
is definitely leeway
and some gray area
there, in terms
of how you want to do that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, they
make a great point about,
how much information--
too much information?
As well as, how much do you
want to make sure is protected?
You don't want to give
away certain details
about the way your system
runs, like how much traffic you
have on it.
So you want to be a little
careful about that as well.
But make sure people
have enough information
to understand what went wrong
and how that got approved.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and they
link to a bunch of prior art
here as well.
Not to say, like-- schadenfreude
or like-- some really good
examples of this being done
where GitLab accidentally
deleted it's
PostgreSQL database.
Its Cloudflare has some issues.
Honeycomb had some issues.
We definitely do this a lot too.
If you look at the
Cloud Status page--
that will link in the
show notes as well--
whenever we have
an outage, you'll
see a little post-mortem
in there as well.
So definitely have a look at how
we do that internally as well.
It's definitely an
interesting thing.
And I think it's good for
customer trust but, also,
as a learning experience for
everyone else who also builds
especially-large
distribution systems.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
All right, I think we covered
the question-of-the-week.
So Mark, where are you going
to be in the next month?
MARK MANDEL: The
next month or so-- so
yeah, as I said
before, I'm going
to be in Montreal in December,
speaking at the Montreal
International Game Summit.
I'm going to Montreal in winter.
I still haven't decided if
this is a good idea or not.
MELANIE WARRICK: I've
actually done that once.
I would highly recommend
bringing a lot of layers.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Bring a lot
of heavy coats and gloves.
But it's really pretty too.
It can be really
pretty with the snow.
MARK MANDEL: I can imagine that.
What are you up to?
What are you doing?
MELANIE WARRICK: So at
the end of this week,
I'm actually participating in
the self-organising conference
on machine learning
that we have at Google.
And it's a conference
that's bringing
in a number of different
external and internal folks
who participate in the
machine learning space
to share knowledge and a
very un-conference style.
And that's going to play out on
Thursday and Friday this week.
And then next week is the
conference that we all
like to go to in the machine
learning, deep learning,
and research
scientist space, known
as NIPS, Neural Information
Processing Systems Conference.
And that's taking place
down in Long Beach.
And that's all next week.
MARK MANDEL: Machine
learning people really
like their acronyms, huh?
MELANIE WARRICK: Sure do.
Really, who doesn't.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's funny how
many acronyms exist out there.
All right, I think
that covers it for us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so Melanie, thank you
for joining me this week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thanks to all
our listeners for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]